we're asked to plot the image of point a
under a reflection across the line L so
we have our line L here and so we want
to plot the image of here a point P plot
the image of point a under reflection
across line L well one way to think
about it is point a is exactly one two
three four units to the right of L and
so it's reflection is going to be four
units to the left of L so if we go one
two three four that would be the image
of point a we could maybe denote that as
a prime so if you're doing this on the
Khan Academy exercise you would actually
just click on a point right over there
and it would show up but this would be
the reflection of point a across the
line L let's do another example so we're
here we're asked plot the image of point
B under a reflection across the x-axis
all right so this is point B and we're
going to reflect it across the x-axis
right over here so to go from B to the
x-axis it's exactly five units below the
x-axis one two three four five so if we
were to reflect across the x-axis
essentially create its mirror image it's
going to be five units above the x-axis
one two three four five so that's where
the image would be maybe we could denote
that with a B Prime we are reflecting
across the x-axis let's do another
example so here they tell us Point C
prime is the image of C which is at the
coordinates negative 4 comma negative
two under a reflection across the y-axis
what are the coordinates of C prime so
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out on your own so there are
several ways to approach it it doesn't
hurt to do a quick visual diagram so oh
that could be my x-axis this would be my
y-axis and it's the point negative 4
comma negative 2 so that might look like
this negative 4 negative 2 so this is
the point
C
right over here and we want to reflect
across the Y axis so we want to reflect
across the Y axis which I am coloring in
and red right over here so let's see the
point C is 4 to the left of the y axis
so it's reflection is going to be 4 to
the right of the y axis so let me do it
like this so instead of being 4 to the
left we want to go 4 to the right so
plus 4 so where would that put our C
Prime so our C prime would be right over
there and what would its coordinates be
well it would have the same y-coordinate
so C prime would have a y-coordinate of
negative 2 but what would its
x-coordinate be well instead of it being
negative 4 it gets flipped over the
y-axis so now it's going to have an x
coordinate of positive 4 so the
coordinates here would be 4 comma
negative 2 4 comma negative 2 you might
have been able to do this in your head
although for me even if I try to do it
in my head I would still have this
visualization going on in my head ok
negative 4 comma negative 2 I'm sitting
there in the 3rd quadrant if I'm
flipping over the y-axis my y-coordinate
wouldn't change but my x coordinate
would become the opposite and I would
end up in the 4th quadrant and that's
exactly what happened why quiet y
coordinate did not change but then my x
coordinate since I'm flipping over the
y-axis it became the negative of this
that opposite of negative 4 which is
positive 4